and getting a mammogram can save your
life October is Breast Cancer Awareness
Month and Nevada health centers are
making it easier for women to get
screened Candace Charles live this
morning with that story Candace good
morning to you
good morning John good morning folks one
of the ways that they're making it
easier is with this the mammal van right
now it's parked in front of La Bonita
Supermarket off of Civic Center Drive
one of the many places they'll be
throughout the month of October for
breast cancer awareness month and really
it is something that is simple we're
going to walk inside to kind of show you
how it works I'm joined by Carrie
Tallman now tell us a little bit about
how this whole thing works it starts
right here when people walk in correct
yeah so just like a brick and mortar
facility people walk through the door
they're going to be greeted by a front
desk person that'll check them in
they'll wait here why they fill out
their insurance information if they have
it and then they'll be asked to go into
a dressing room where they're going to
basically put on a gown and then they'll
Venture on into the back where they'll
do the actual screening and that's with
this equipment that is going to
basically compress the breast so that we
can get a good reading of the breast
tissue now I know one of the things that
women have said is that they're scared
of doing this because the equipment may
look scary but honestly this doesn't
look like anything that's scary and how
does it really go I mean is it painful
at all no it's not painful it's
basically just a compression of the
breast tissue some people describe it
more as discomfort it is not painful I
mean if people are if the tech is you
know experienced and doing it right it
is not painful it's a very quick squeeze
too it maybe lasts like 15 seconds at
most and then there's a release so yeah
it's not painful at all so this whole
process is fairly quick I mean just
walked through here ourselves and didn't
take very long usually you know you have
to wait when you go to an office so how
helpful is this for the community yeah I
think for a lot of women just feeling
like they can't take time out for any
kind of appointment because they're
caregivers you know they got children or
their
adults parents that they're caring for
so taking time for any appointment is
challenging but they can download
paperwork for this bring it with them
literally the entire appointment lasts
20 minutes it's super fast yes super
quick very helpful for people thank you
so much Carrie for telling us I
appreciate it now they do have donors
that have been helping them out making
this all possible but your destinations
really do help so if you'd like to
donate you can do so when you come down
here you can do so on their website
we'll have those details for you all
nateneesnow.com as well as the details
on all the other locations that you can
find them in band this month for now
live from Candace Charles 8 news now all
right Candace thank you very much it's
quick and it's so important for for
women to get checked so appreciate that